it all happened so fast
there was a solar flare
goodbye crops and food goodbye
everything
so i
had
frightened
and so alone
and i found you
[Music]
what should we have
get your elbows off the table keep your
elbows up
all right you're next
you see i'm developing something
interesting
giant leap of faith
now if you can speak
tell me something
about you the robots must protect
morning dog we don't go before that
storm hits we'll die all of us
as soon as you can walk we're leaving
one two one two one
that's falling
[Music]
head west over the mountains would you
like me to drive
don't over steer
that's oversteer honey ease your foot up
just a hair
perfect
[Music]
i don't think it likes me
come and see this
tie the rv down
hang on to something
[Music]
we should be safe once we get into the
mountains those things will happen
like 150 degree heat
uv radiation
and people
hiding in the shadows
do you think we'll make it
not without my team
what we do
we do together
i believe in you this
[Music]
you